good morning uh from London my name is
Banu patnaga thank you for joining uh
today's who Europe uh press briefing
where we will provide an update on the
Urgent health needs and response uh in
Turkey including Emergency Medical Teams
operating in the field Following last
week's devastating earthquakes uh before
heading over to the regional director Dr
Hans Kluger to make his opening
statement let me briefly introduce our
panelists joining from Turkey today
we're also ready to respond to your
questions uh from Adena in southern
turkey we are joined by Dr Bhatia bergy
klichev he's the who is representative
Intercare and also in Adena Dr uh Flavio
salio who's Global Network leader for
the Emergency Medical Teams thank you
both so much for joining us so without
further delay uh Regional director
Kruger you have the floor
let me just fix the uh camera angle
quickly
there you go and
good morning everyone first and foremost
on behalf of all of us at the who
regional office for Europe
and over doubly to Country office in
Turkey
I would like to reiterate our heartfelt
condolences to the people of turkey and
Syria
your suffering is immense your grief
profounds who stands with you in your
hour of needs and always
as of now more than 31 000 people have
lost their lives to the earthquakes in
Turkey
the number of injured almost 100 000
people
across the border in Northwest Syria the
death toll is nearly five thousands and
all of these figures will likely rise
we have at the same time been witnessing
miraculous rescue efforts by teams of
heroic Turkish responders working around
the clock in a desperate Race Against
Time
we are inspired by them and draw
strength from their efforts
yesterday they saved
Murray a young girl living in adjaman
from the rebel of a block of flats
she had been trapped for
178 hours
at who we have been urging all parties
government and Civil Society alike to
work together to ensure cross-border
delivery of humanitarian AIDS between
turkey and Syria and within Syria itself
the needs are huge increasing by the
hour
some 26 million people across both
countries need humanitarian assistance
we working with many partners are
supporting the massive humanitarian
response to Safe lives treat the injured
and crucially help get the health system
particularly Primary Health Care back up
and running
however daunting that seems at the
present moment
over the past week we have dispatched
three charter flights packed with
emergency kits and medical supplies
the stand for both Syria and turkey
enough to treat 400 000 people
as well as conduct 120
000 urine surgeries and more supplies on
the way second
we have deployed technical search teams
to the disaster Zone to conduct
urgent Public Health needs assessment
and support our existing field offices
in the area
third we have initiated the deployment
of Emergency Medical Teams and fourth
released 16 million dollars from our
contingency fund for emergencies to help
people in need
just over a week since this terrible
trilogy there are also growing concerns
over emerging health issues linked to
the cold weather hygiene and sanitation
and the spread of infectious diseases
with vulnerable people especially at
risk
we stand beside the Ministry of Health
Dr farhart in goja and the Turkish
Ministry of Health
who reported critical vaccine supplies
including against tetanus and radius
have been sent to the Quake Zone and
mobile pharmacies have begun operating
in Turkey an estimated 1 million people
have lost their homes and are living in
temporary shelters
according to the Turkish authorities
an estimated 80 000 people are in
hospital
placing a huge strain on the health
system itself badly damaged by the
disaster
the World Health Organization has
launched a 43 million dollar appeal to
support the earthquake response in Syria
and turkey
but I expect this to at least double
over the coming days
as we get a better assessment of the
massive scale of this crisis and the
needs
this money will be used to ensure access
to the most vulnerable and hard to reach
populations
to provide trauma care and post trauma
Rehabilitation
to provide essential medicines and
emergency kids to fill urgent Healthcare
gaps
to deliver vital mental and psychosocial
support of the affected populations and
to ensure continuity of routine Health
Services especially for women children
the elderly and those with
non-communical diseases
we have initiated the largest deployment
of emergency medical teams in the
Doubletree region in our 75 year history
22 emerging Medical Teams have arrived
in Turkey so far
these specialized teams from 19
countries will integrate into Turkish
ongoing Health response providing
critical emergency care
their immediate priority will be to
support the many hospitals and medical
facilities
that have been damaged working
particularly to deal with the high
number of trauma patients and
catastrophic injuries
now is the time for the International
Community
to show the same generosity that turkey
has shown to all the nations globally
over the years
the country is home to the largest
Refugee population in the world
4.2 million people from neighboring
Syria many of whom have lost everything
again
we are witnessing the worst natural
disaster
in the who European region for a century
and we are still learning about its
magnitude
it's true cost is not known yet
recovery and hearing will take time and
a phenomenal effort
but I can assure you that the who will
remain steadfast alongside the people of
turkey and Syria for as long as it takes
thank you thank you very much uh
Regional director uh for those uh
opening remarks uh so without further
Ado uh we will open the floor to
questions uh for the regional director
or our panelists uh in Turkey uh if
you'd like to ask a question please uh
raise your hand in the system uh and ask
your question uh esmir please over to
you please unmute yourself
thank you for giving me a floor uh
director General you mentioned the
diseases and uh what could come after
um all of this especially with the
health systems uh in the injury in both
countries in turkey and Syria how
worried you are about that situation
especially with the weather uh going to
the warmer uh temperatures in the later
part of uh this year and um how you will
assist to both countries to deal with
all these issues especially in the
cities which are most hearted hit by
these earthquakes thank you
thank you Arty thank you esmir so the
top priority
remains on life-saving interventions
trauma care emergency medical support
search and rescue because still there
are quite a number of
aftershocks
which you should be aware about but as
you say
that independent actually of the weather
conditions
because water and sanitation facilities
or also hit
we are increasing Public Health
surveillance and have to be ready for
communicable diseases outbreaks and
hence routine immunization comes into
the picture as well uh thank you very
much original director perhaps uh Dr
salio Dr flavis salio maybe you have a
little bit to add from the EMT
perspective the emergency medical team
perspective and dealing with some of
these uh potential outbreaks
yes thanks uh I think we have done
through our Global calls so we we
request a team capacity to pick uh to
basically to take the first wave of
trauma patients and our original
director mentions at the same time
obviously we are expecting possible
complications uh as a standard response
to such kind of disaster in the next few
few weeks and at the same time it has
already mentioned it'd be the scale up
of primary health care services in way
to ensure that Essential Health Services
are are provided and this is basically
the strategy that's been adopted so far
thank you very much Dr Salia we have a
question in the chat
um and I I I think I'll go to Dr bath
here for for this one but what specific
measures uh are being taken to tackle
potential sanitation issues Beyond
monitoring and vaccination so what sort
of support might the who be providing to
the Turkish authorities and indeed our
own programmatic work to handle some of
the sanitation issues
yes thank you for the question indeed uh
damage severe damage to water and
sanitation system it's a great concern
and it increases the risk of waterborne
diseases and outbreaks of communicable
diseases we at the country level work
jointly under the UN country team
mechanism because this uh disaster
requires comprehensive response
including water provision protection
sanitation food and shelter so we
coordinate with various line Ministries
through the UN mechanism it's also
Beyond Ministry of Health and of course
under the circumstances to prevent this
outbreak of diseases first it's a
provision of Safe Water because in some
places that water being provision of
setup water was interrupted so there is
a supply of water drinkable water as a
first and of course we are dealing with
the health authorities to establish and
strengthen surveillance system because
it's not only waterborne diseases but
also it's a seasonal influence and covet
and people displaced people in a crowded
communal settings also more exposed to
risk of outbreaks
thank you very much uh so let's take on
the next question from Ivana bosevic RTS
Serbia please ask your question
I think you're still muted there we go
nope we can't hear you
try no I'm afraid to kind of maybe type
your question in the chat if that's okay
in the meantime uh I might go to some
other questions that we have received uh
from from the media while we wait for uh
ivana's question in the chat
um and maybe uh I might go to both uh Dr
Berta cleavage and and uh Dr salio on
this because we've been getting
questions on what some of the expected
demands uh are on the health services uh
you know at this time at this
unprecedented time how does the health
system need to uh need to respond to
this crisis
maybe over to you first uh Dr bardike
yes thank you very much uh I I have to
say that first Focus was on the
life-saving supplies delivering trauma
and surgical kits coordination of
Emergency Medical Teams arrival to the
country
however the acute phase of the disaster
is almost over and of course we have
other health issues becoming more
obvious it's Interruption of routine
Health Services
uh we need now to focus on trauma
Rehabilitation
and also looking at the primary health
care because after visiting several
provinces we see that it's Hospital
infrastructure but also Primary Health
scale level severely affected by this
earthquake
so a growing problem also surveillance
as we already talked about it and the
possibility of outbreaks so what we are
currently doing jointly with the
Ministry of Health we're conducting
rapid needs assessment in the most
affected areas to form and identify
response plan with the support of
Partners and donors
um also to mention that growing problem
would be and already we can see that
it's a traumatized population so the
need for psychological and Mental Health
Services would be increased in this
regard so it's a preliminary period
before the Reconstruction starts to
ensure uninterrupted Health Services
provision and Public Health Services
thank you thanks uh Flavia would you
anything to add
yeah yeah I think uh is a question of um
capability and scalability as since the
beginning so I think uh in in the in the
in the future what what we are what we
expect is what uh drabati really uh
presented uh Primary Care Services entry
points as a way obviously to ensure that
uh the services are provided and then
increase in the level of coordination in
which uh in the way we're going to match
the gaps identify with available
resources and capability in uh in the
field
many thanks uh Flavia so we'll take
Ivana bosevich's question and uh Ivana
has asked what impact do you expect on
Mental Health uh uh and in terms of what
you have noticed what you've observed
and how can WHIO help Regional director
will go to you first
yes as a principal Ivana
mental health conditions increase
in all emergencies
for obvious reasons direct or indirect
impact
unfortunately
the earthquake in our region in turkey
and Syria is not the only emergency
obviously it's the biggest
natural disaster in the century but we
see in the other emergencies as well
the need to scale up Mental Health
Services
which are to be part of any assistance
provided
let's give the floor to our colleagues
what they are observing on the field so
uh Pastor maybe you'd like to come in on
some of the mental health impacts
expected mental health impacts uh not
just now in the short term but in the in
the months and potentially years ahead
uh of course as we going out of the
acute phase the need for the
psychological and mental health support
would be only growing and This Disaster
would have long lasting effect on the
population people only now start
realizing what happened to them after
this shock period we before the
earthquake we had a strong uh
collaboration in the area of Mental
Health Services with the Ministry of
Health with the ministry of family and
social Affairs what we can do and the
negotiating currently with the
authorities it's a trainer of counselors
so that they can organize these services
and a rich population in the affected
areas but also there are many people who
were displaced to other areas of turkey
and they would also need to be rich with
that services
many thanks for that there's a question
now here from from Tracy on death tolls
I think this might also need well it
could be to Flavio or batir but when it
comes to the numbers we receive how are
they calculated who is reporting the
death toll
um I I maybe not I may be not aware of
the details of the national but there is
a national coordination mechanism where
all information is collected and those
figures are announced on a daily basis
and actually you can see them you know
live TV channels
many thanks uh so the next question here
from Megan Ford I think Flavio I might
come to you because I think there's an
element here of EMTs and hopefully you
can also tell us a little bit more about
the EMT deployments but uh Megan is
asking are nurses part of the emergency
response teams and how have nurses been
supporting uh the responsive efforts uh
if at all and then maybe a little bit
about uh the EMTs that you are
coordinating on the ground thank you
thanks I mean first of all nurses are
very critical functions in all the team
and and hospital for sure are integrated
as part of of the team together with the
uh specialized uh um Physicians and and
alliances and Technical uh auxiliary
medical stuff what we see what we are
seeing today is that obviously
unprecedented as well movement of uh
volunteers uh with the with the level of
capacity to complement the facilities
those facilities been augmented the
capacity has been augmented through the
deployment of emergency medical team
priority is being given at those teams
they have the capacity to provide
emergency care services including
surgeries in the way clearly to augment
the capacity of the local Services local
services that is quite obvious they feel
uh the significant level of Destruction
and we notice obviously the fatigue on
on the wall workers and then clearly the
need of well to care for for their
relatives and and family so it is that's
the reason why actually we call for a
team with a stronger capacities to be
located in in the Strategic location to
complement the capacities of the
hospital and now we say in the second
phase looking more to those teams that
will have the capacity to increase the
primary care services as well
many thanks uh Flavio we have another
question here uh on uh do you already
have full access to victims or survivors
in Syria uh resource director would you
like to take a stability sure I would
like to acknowledge that this is a joint
effort with my colleague the origin
director of the history majoring region
Dr Ahmed al-mandari and his team and our
teams are working very closely together
The Witches cross-border operations into
Northwest Syria is based out of the who
office in gaziantev and supports a
population of over 4.6 million people
since the earthquake who has shipped
over 250 metric tons of medicines and
supplies
and these included seven trucks
containing 74 metric tons of who
emergency trauma kits essential
medicines and supplies including
materials received on the first Charter
flight from Dubai
that crossed into Northwest area on the
11th of
February which are sufficient to provide
3.2 million treatments
courses
the U.N resumed its cross-border
operation on 9 February following three
days of temporary disruption due to the
damaged roads
and the second eight convoices the
earthquakes hits crossed from Turkey to
Northwest Syria on the 10th of February
with 14 trucks and further convoys
or plant
many thank you many thanks for that
um if there's no further questions
online I'll take maybe one more question
that we received an advanced Flavio I
think I'll come to you for this one and
it's about
um you know a weekend now we are still
hearing you know remarkable stories of
people being pulled from the rubble but
How likely is it now uh for search and
rescue operations to well be successful
I mean um social respiration are still
uh are still ongoing in uh in in certain
areas uh uh vital obviously to uh to
continue looking for uh possible uh
under under the rubble and as well as uh
increasing those Services uh in in the
area where social rescue operations are
ongoing at the same time it's uh after
the the initial uh week of operations we
have seen a significant amount as well
of medical evacuations has been
conducted in terms of Civilian injuries
that have been clearly taken out of the
rubble and then have been transferred
immediately to their peripheral
facilities I think that's a level of
coordination it's uh it's it's
impressive
many thanks uh for that Flavio and uh on
that note
um if there's no further questions
online uh I'm going to wrap the Press
briefing for today um I'd like to just
give the floor one final time to the
regional director
thank you the last question I just want
to reiterate that it is absolutely
critical to ensure access to healthcare
for all those who need it regardless of
where they may be
and regarding Northwest Syria we hope to
find a solution to ensure a constant
flow of supplies together with other
event Partners other International
Partners civil society and be able to
reach all those in need
as the concluding remarks for this press
briefing once again
I would like to express my sincere
condolences
to all the affected communities
in Turkey
in Syria and express appreciation
to the minister of Health Dr fahartin
KOJA
and his team for his leadership and
coordination with who and the
International Community 24 7.
thank you for joining
I wish all of you a strong health and
thank you very much members of the press
if you have any follow-ups please do
email us at EU press at who dot int as
always stay healthy take care bye